[Music]
[Applause]
he's the voice of the Yankees he's
Michael K from the S network and uh the
Yankees still in Toronto and then they
head on to Cincinnati and Michael joins
us now Mike thanks for joining us let me
go back to the other night with Aaron
judge with his little side-eyed look to
wherever he was looking did you notice
anything at that time
no because we were more fixated on the
fact that Boone just got thrown out Dan
uh so we're working the the center field
camera from far away we're not zooming
in on his eyes I don't know if Toronto
was tipped off that something like this
could happen
that was certainly not even a point of
of observation by either me or or David
Cohn or our producer and director
because we're on a uh the center field
camera never saw his eyes
then did you understand what was going
on or the controversy when did you
realize that there was uh at least a
question mark attached to this
after the game uh because it was in the
eighth inning and got that happen and
then he hit the monster home run I think
it became a big thing they showed the
ice guarding band and then obviously
hits this home run 462 feet so after the
game just looking through social media
you could see that the the darting eyes
became a thing and that's certainly
something that people are going to run
with because you've got the reigning MVP
the guy who broke the American League
home run record last year who has a
pristine reputation so uh this is gonna
make people think a little bit and it
did you had the Blue Jays pitcher who
said that his he was tipping his pitches
or he was told he was tipping his
pitches
um I had a couple of questions with this
if judge is looking over but he's
disappointed in his teammates they're
chirping
at the time and that he can't step out
of the box and say guys will you stop or
whatever it might be but he's tipping
his pitches your first base Third Base
coaches are not in the coaching boxes as
well that they're up a little bit higher
so maybe they could look in for a signal
let's play conspiracy theorists here is
there any can you see even though you're
not maybe neutral being the Yankee
broadcaster is there any validity to any
of this with Aaron judge maybe trying to
get some kind of an advantage
well that's exactly what happened I mean
he first of all he didn't call timeout
he you only have one time out hurry back
and he had already called it and the way
he was starting his eyes there's no way
his teammates could see that he was
darting his eyes you know I was told
later you know he was trying to like see
who was talking
uh so he could address it later all of
that is all fun and games what happened
was that the Yankees were doing good
old-fashioned baseball games and
they picked up the tip they picked up a
tell and they knew what pitch he was
going to throw uh and so it would
probably be relayed by Travis Chapman
the first base coach uh and when when uh
when judges asked about it later Dan you
know you can't admit that you don't want
the Blue Jays kinds yeah so he said that
he was looking into the about the
chirping and the chirping up probably
sure did bother him because it was going
on for quite a while they were up six
nothing but he obviously received uh a
tip from Travis Chapman and there's
nothing wrong with that that's been
going on baseball for 130 years as long
as you don't pick up a sign
electronically there's nothing wrong
with it it's it just tells the Blue Jays
be better be tighter even John Schneider
said that you have to protect their
signs better and and as for the coaches
being out of the box I don't know again
I guess every single one of the 60 base
coaches in baseball stand out of the box
for one reason you don't want to get
killed I mean it was Arnold Stanton and
Aaron judge uh you really think that
Luis Rojas wants to be close to the the
Box he's going to be down the left field
line or he can get killed what do you
see in Aaron judge if there's anything
different this year as a as opposed to
last year
just locked in he actually wants to be
better uh and uh he was working on some
things in a two-strike approach during
spring training which I think he's put
to the back burner but uh you look at
his numbers and remember he missed 10
games well with the hip injury and his
numbers are still extraordinary with 11
home runs uh he's just uh he's one of
the best players in baseball if it
wasn't for Otani who was a unicorn I
think you could say he's clearly the
best player in baseball he's in the
middle of his prime he's amazing and you
know what else I see Dan he's incredibly
beloved by his teammates and you and I
have been around athletes a long time
sometimes the stars are not like that
much there's jealousy people don't wish
the best for them in Quiet Moments when
he hit that 60 second home run last year
Dan every single Yankee was his
Overjoyed for him as he was for himself
and I think that continues to this day
he embodies everything that you want a
captain to be so uh the Yankees had to
bring him back they wanted to bring him
back and obviously he did come back and
I don't see the money or the length of
contract affecting him at all I'm still
amazed at some of the pitches he hits
out Mike because
they look like meatballs I'm I'm still
amazed that you don't either go inside
or go outside like I have to treat him
like Barry Bonds I I there's a bread box
there and I'm not going into that bread
box if he hits a bad ball home run God
bless him but some of these pitches it
feels like batting practice for him
is it just the pitching today and you
know there are pro I mean they're
they're throwers they're not many
pitchers
well I was amazed all year Dan
especially in the second half of last
year when everybody was hurt but hit he
really carried the Yankees during that
stretch and that people were still
pitching to him but then when he got
close to 60 all of a sudden the pitchers
and the teams didn't want to be the
victims of the of the Milestone home
runs so they were very careful and they
walked him and it took him a long time
to get those home runs because of the
way people approached them I'm still
stunned that they don't pitch to him and
treat him like Barry Bonds because why
would you pitch them because you'd say
okay even when Stan's Healthy You Gotta
face stand or Rizzo behind him and
they're both buying players but wouldn't
you rather take your chances with them
than with Aaron judge and even now
they're right back to challenging him
and what did Einstein say if you do the
same thing over and over in the results
are the same well this Insanity so I
mean good for him good for the fans to
watch him hit home runs but it is a
little odd and one other thing about you
know darting of the eyes and getting the
pitch maybe from Chapman Dan you would
have hit that wall over the left field
wall it was a hanging slider there's no
sign for that
uh well I would admit that I cheated
though I I would say yes I got I got
tipped off plus didn't didn't the
pitcher throw like six consecutive
sliders like at one point you go uh how
about something else
right I don't think he had to be told
that another slide was coming oh sorry
the guy's 35 years old I believe he's
been on 12 teams uh three different
countries uh and you know it was a
moment for him but he he really threw a
really bad pitch so even if you picked
up location I don't think they were
picking up pitches then because
obviously it's given by pitchcom so they
were picking up location the location
was blown away he clearly missed the
location yes so the Tipping of the
location didn't help judging that home
run
um Diego Hermon with the illegal
substance what do you think he had on
his hand there Michael
I think they put like an overabundance
of rosin and sweat and it gets really
really sticky and I think that one thing
that baseballs should do and believe me
Dan I'm not absorbing Oman when you've
already been ticketed like and you know
the guys behind the sign on the Merit
you don't go fast by that sign he was
already stopped against the Minnesota
Twins on Jackie Robinson day and he did
the same thing that is not that smart
now I think that baseball has to give a
baseline this is what's acceptable this
is what's not every single umpire has
this different opinion of what sticky is
and uh James Hoy said he's never seen a
hand that sticky yesterday so I'm sure
Boone didn't argue I'm a boom looked
like he was pretty chapped at her mom
but they've got to come up with a
substance this is what you could put on
your hand this is how much you could put
on it and another thing I think they
should do as well Dan if you look at her
mom's spin rates they didn't go up
so I mean what's the sticky stuff for
other than get a better feeling maybe
command of the pitch but if they go up
300 400 revolutions then you know
they're using the sticky stuff for
something nefarious but I think that
even Max shares it his his RPMs did not
go up that much I think that's what
should be looked at and if you see a
spike in the RPMs then obviously that's
when you could step in and check the
hand if the angels are out of the
playoff Chase
by the trade deadline
could you see the Yankees making an
offer for Otani
I could see every team making an offer
but the dangerous part is I think that
Otani is going to become a free agent so
if the angels are going to trade one of
the greatest players who ever lived
they're going to want a big big return
do you want a big big return going to
the angels and you might have to be a
guy for two months now there's some
school of thought well let's get them
show them how great it is here and then
all of a sudden he'll he'll be more apt
to sign this guy's gonna cost over 50
million dollars a year I don't know if
anybody's going to give up to the angels
what they need to give up just for a
two-month rental could it happen I think
everybody would be interested at the
right price but I I think Artie Moreno
is going to try to keep him too I mean
how do you let that guy go because not
only is he a great player he makes a
team a lot of money off the field yeah
but does he want to stay all he has to
do is look around and see Mike Trout and
go that guy's got three playoff games in
a Hall of Fame career
it's funny Dan I sat next to um ohtani
when he he just signed with the Angels
uh this was at the baseball writer's
dinner in New York and you know he he
said to me you know he speaks English
pretty well he goes why is everybody so
upset that I didn't come to New York I
said because they wanted you to play her
they wanted to see you play and he goes
well maybe next time but I know at that
point he wanted to you know he wanted to
be on the west coast closer to Japan
maybe that's changed right now I think
he would be uh somewhat short-sighted to
eliminate the New York Yankees and the
New York Mets and Steve Cohen's Oodles
of money even if you don't want to go
there at least play the game so you can
up the Dodgers offer and the Padres
offer and he and the angels offer but I
think he's going to consider everybody
and I don't think he's as intimidated
about the East Coast anymore
good to talk to you Michael thanks for
joining us
anytime Dan have a great day Michael K
Yankee play-by-play announcer for your
YES Network had a lot to talk about
tonight tomorrow in Toronto then they
head to Cincinnati